>> YES.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT.
MATT FINN IN ST. LOUIS.
MATT, THANKS.
PARTICIPANTS IN EVERYTHING
FROM FANTASY FOOTBALL TO
MARCH MADNESS POOLS TO BIG
DOLLAR WAGERING ON GAMES AND
MATCHES ARE REJOICING
TONIGHT.
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT HAS
RULED A FEDERAL LAW BANNING
SPORTS GAMBLING IN MOST
STATES IS ILLEGAL.
MY COLLEAGUE AND CO-ANCHOR
AT TONIGHT SHANNON BREAM
TELLS US WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> TODAY THE U.S. SUPREME
COURT DECISION IS SET TO UP
END THE WORLD OF SPORTS
GAMBLING.
BLOCKING STATES FROM
SPONSORING, OPERATING,
ADVERTISING, PROMOTING
LICENSING OR AUTHORIZING
SPORTS GAMBLING IN MOST ALL
SITUATIONS.
BUT.
>> WHAT THEY REALLY SAID WAS
THAT CONGRESS DOESN'T HAVE
THE RIGHT TO TELL STATE
LEGISLATORS WHAT TO DO.
THAT SHOULD BE UP TO
LEGISLATORS AND THE VOTERS.
>> JUDGE ALITO LIKENED THE
LAW TO POSTING FEDERAL
OFFICERS IN STATE CHAMBERS
ARMED WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
STOP LAWMAKERS FROM VOTING.
QUOTE:  A MORE DIRECT
AFFRONT TO STATE SOVEREIGNTY
IS NOT EASY TO IMAGINE.
JUSTICE GINSBURG WRITING THE
DISSENT ARGUED THE COURT
COULD HAVE USED RESTRAINT IN
NULLIFYING THE FEDERAL LAW
RATHER THAN, QUOTE:  DEPLOY
A WRECKING BALL.
ADDING WHEN A STATUTE
REVEALS A CONSTITUTIONAL
FLAW, THE COURT ORDINARILY
ENGAGES IN A SALVAGE RATHER
THAN A DEMOLITION OPERATION.
THOUSAND PLAYS OUT WITH
LIVER.
STATES LIKE NEW JERSEY,
DELAWARE, NEW JERSEY AND
MISSISSIPPI ARE EXPECTED TO
MOVE QUICKLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE FRAMEWORK
ALREADY IN PLACE AT THE
STATE LEVEL.
GAMING ANALYSTS EXPECT AS
MANY AS 32 STATES TO OFFER
LEGAL BETTING WITHIN THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS.
THERE IS A FEDERAL LAW IN
PLACE THAT APPEARS TO BAN
GAMBLING ACROSS STATE LINES.
MEANING STATES THAT DO MOVE
FORWARD WITH LEGALIZED
GAMBLING WILL HAVE TO TACKLE
THE ISSUE OF POLICING THEIR
OWN CYBER BORDERS.
WITH TODAY'S OPINION TO
CLEARLY BACKING STATES'
RIGHTS SOME EXPECT OTHER
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES COULD
SOON BE RIPE FOR THE
PICKING.
>> THIS COULD IMPACT
ANYTHING FROM MARIJUANA, GUN
LAWS, REALLY WHAT THE COURT
AFFIRMED WAS CONGRESS CANNOT
COME MEN DEER THE STATES.
>> WE ARE STILL AWAITING
DECISIONS IN SEVERAL HIGH
PROFILE CASES INCLUDING
DISPUTES OVER RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY.